[Musique]
je vais vous demander de fermer les yeux
et de vous laisser porter quelques
instants imaginez vous êtes seul tout
seul
la mairie forme
voir des formes
le bateau bouge beaucoup levac tap la
coque avec puissance
le vent est super
les rafales dépassent les 30 des vagues
de la taille d'un immeuble de quatre
étages défection le plus grand bassin
elle le chahut comme une bringue la mer
est maintenant des notes
taclé grandiose et inquiétant telle une
énorme machine à laver la mer ranches
attaques plus puissantes plus
impressionné les crêtes sont blanches à
céret prête à avaler
il résiste craque le vent s'intensifie
inlassable sans enfant
l'amérique al
hélas il y à un vent ce qu'il a vu une
mer hachée et croisée
violentée majuscule
quelle incroyable spectacle vous sentez
petit
milieu de cette immensité
une telle intensité une telle beauté
conforte trop belle
voilà on pouvait ouvrir vos yeux et
revenir sur terre vers ce que vous venez
de vivre fut mon quotidien pendant 42
jours
et oui j'ai ya 7 ans j'ai pris une
décision inattendue de traverser l'océan
atlantique à la rame en solitaire sans
assistance et sans escale entre dakar et
cayenne j'ai mis 42 jours oui 42 jours
alors fou extraordinaire me direz vous
peut-être peut-être pas mais au fond
qu'est ce que c'est 42 jours dans une
vie surtout qui semblerait qu'on en ait
qu'une et c'est pourquoi je vais vous
raconter ses 42 jours qui ont bouleversé
ma vie et mon fêtant grandir vous vous
doutez qu'il ya une question qu'on m'a
posée un nombre incalculable de fois ce
fameux pourquoi qu'est ce qui a bien pu
pousser il ya sept ans a traversé
l'atlantique à la rame en solitaire sans
assistance et sans escale entre dakar et
cayenne alors qu'entre nous il ya un peu
plus simple pour relier deux océans
je suis alors marié et le suis toujours
j'ai deux enfants de 7 et 10 ans je suis
cadre commercial dans une pme
je ne suis pas marin du tout la première
nuit j'ai passé en mer seul
c'est au large de dakar je suis sportif
et en aucun cas de haut niveau j'aime à
dire je suis un sportif à mon niveau
et figurez vous je n'aime pas l'eau qui
nagent comme une vraie paire de
tenailles
alors est ce que c'est un coup de folie
un défi un délire la crise de la
quarantaine
quoi d'autre encore soyons clairs je me
suis pas levé un matin comme certains
vous savez en se rasant devant leur
glace tiens et si je traversé
l'atlantique à la rame
totalement impossible je ne savais même
pas qu'on pouvait le faire
alors moi la vie réputé ordinaire
comment si je retrouvais dans une telle
galère
c'est l'histoire d'un type qui débarque
en totale ignorant à son premier salon
nautique à paris et ce type c'est moi et
j'écoute un copain qui me dit viens tu
verras c'est génial il ya des bateaux de
rêve
et en plus on va boire des coups tous
les deux franchement j'ai plutôt été
pour boire des coups avec mon pote que
voir des bateaux mais effectivement j'en
prends plein les yeux
moi qui n'avais jamais vu un bateau hors
d'eau c'est super impressionnant et je
découvre des bateaux de course au format
serre et enfin plus surprenants les uns
que les autres qui au détour d'un stand
au loin jouer une espèce de bulle de
tintin enfin une aile d'avion a pas très
au clair avec ce machin donc guidé par
ma curiosité je me rapproche de cet
objet flottant non identifié
et là à ma grande surprise je constate
qu'il ya un poste d'aviron classique en
coulisses des dames de nage des rails
enfin comme un rameur dans une salle de
sport quoi qu'est ce que c'est que ce
machin
à quoi ça peut bien servir et là il ya
un petit bonhomme je préfère utiliser
plus petit que moi quoi faudrait le
faire quoi plus âgé qui me demande si je
veux des renseignements tu m'étonnes que
j'ai reçu c'est quoi ce machin
ça sert à quoi hellemmes explique super
calmement il dit c'est un aviron
océanique qui a été conçu donc c'est à
dire qu'il ya des mecs qu'on réfléchisse
à sa pour traverser l'océan atlantique
en solitaire sans assistance et sans
escale
un peu comme ce qu'avait réalisé gérard
d'aboville alors là ma réaction a été
immédiate jeudi mais fou est un grand
malade quoi pour faire un truc comme ça
où une force de la nature veut peut-être
même les deux d'ailleurs pile les deux
choses que je ne suis pas ni tard et ni
une force de la nature
et là il me dit super calmement banon tu
vois moi je les fais ya deux ans et
j'avais 52 ans
je le regarde jamais sérieusement tu te
fous de moi quoi tu me prends pour un
week end six semaines c'est pas possible
tu es en train de me dire qu'un mec
comme moi qui n'ai aucune expérience de
la mer de la navigation et de tout le
reste d'ailleurs peut traverser
l'atlantique à la rame et là il me
répond super calmement mais oui bien sûr
la décision te revient elle ne dépend
que de toi
la décision de revient ne dépend que de
toi ils me saluent super élégamment va
renseigner quelqu'un d'autre et je suis
resté sur le stand comme un con j'ai
déambulé un trouble et mais je dois le
reconnaître les yeux qui pétillent déjà
je me suis pris en fait un peu comme un
gros électrochoc une décharge électrique
et je me surprends à rêver a rêvé d'
aventure à rêver de liberté et je ne
sais pas pourquoi au fond je sens que
j'ai une furieuse envie de le faire et
je le sais si je ne le fais pas
maintenant je ne le ferai jamais et on à
te sentir et des rêves pour des bonnes
raisons du moment un mois plus tard je
décide d'embrasser laventure mais avec
un énorme à angres a majuscule et je
pense certainement la décision la plus
folle de ma vie enfin près mon mariage
bien sûr
sauter dans l'inconnu de la haute mer en
solitaire à la rame sans assistance et
sans escale sur une coquille de noix et
cette folie fera de moi un aventurier
rien ne me destinait a priori à être
aventuriers je me suis simplement
autorisés à le devenir
je me suis simplement autorisés à le
devenir
c'est quoi au juste en fait cette
traversée j'ouvre en une image plus de
4000 personnes ont gravi l'everest en
2012 moins de trente personnes au monde
avait réussi cette traversée de 4700 km
entre l'île de gorée à dakar et lille et
de l'enfant perdu à cayenne qui porte
bien son nom d'ailleurs mon terrain de
jeu c'est un plan d'eau de 5000 km de
long sur 2500 km de large soit 23 fois
la superficie de la france
les marins l'appel everest d'arrout sud
car ce sont deux océans qui s'affrontent
comme des montagnes qui se déplace et se
croisent en permanence c'est pas hyper
rassurant comme à faire mais cette
traversée c'est surtout un million de
coups de rame 1 million le premier truc
que je me suis dit pour rester un peu
positifs ti pierre va falloir partager
là on va faire cinq cent mille par bras
ça donne l'impression qu' on a deux fois
moins mais en réalité c'est tout de même
entre 10 et 12 heures de rame
quotidienne et c'est surtout 30
bénévoles impliqués qui m'accompagne
pour aller au bout de cette aventure
seules on ne fait rien seul on ne fait
rien
et la liste des peurs la liste des peur
la solitude le mental la fatigue et pipi
caca à gérer la hauteur des vagues et
j'en oublie volontairement
soyons honnête il n'y a aucune bonne
raison de faire une aventure comme celle
là ok mais il ya une multitude de
raisons de ne pas la faire en clair
c'est totalement déraisonnable
d'ailleurs mon père me lis pierre
m'était complètement con quoi ta pote
chose à [ __ ] que ça t'es marié tu as
des enfants
tu as une situation tapez autre chose à
[ __ ] que ça et ma mère c'est ma mère
pierre je te rappelle que tu n'aime pas
l'eau
comme moi et c'est là que j'ai appris
que finalement elle avait failli se
noyer petit donc ma peur de l'eau
c'était la sienne et moi qui ai toujours
rêvé de faire un paris dakar à moto ces
mecs là me faisait rêver quand j'étais
petit mais mercier toujours reposer trop
dangereux elle elle me dit pierre quoi
tu ferais pas un pareil dakar plus tôt
l'asa la dérangeait pas et je traverse
le désert à 180 non ça ne dérangeait pas
tout ça pour vous dire encore une fois
on n'est pas maître de ce destin là mais
j'aimerais quand même vous racontez vous
partagez une dernière anecdote
mon fils valentin 10 ans alors c'est est
missionné comme mon coach sportif mon
fils mon coach et valentin il est féru
de bmx
c'est un sport très explosif ces
quarante secondes de course à vélo et
pilote de front c'est très intense et un
jour d'entraînement me donne un conseil
tel qu'il le sens il me dit pierre papa
il faut absolument que tu gardes des
forces pour sprinter aller à fond à
l'arrivée je suis explique judith c'est
valentin je vais être seul et le bateau
fenton donc il est peu probable
je puisse le sprinter mais je te promets
d'y penser valentin je te le promets
figurez vous que j'ai failli ne jamais
passer cette saloperie de ligne en
pleine nuit je me prends la bascule
démarrer les vents tournants découvrir
des courants contraires puissant bref au
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment
après 15 heures de rame d'affilée je
mets 5 heures pour faire le dernier
kilomètre je me fais systématiquement
envoyés au large est renvoyé au large
épuisant après dix tentatives
infructueuses
d'un coup je vois le visage de valentin
et entend son conseil et là je donne
tout je sprinte comme un dingue et je
passe la ligne
donc oui ces mêmes mots qui m'avait fait
sourire ont permis de lutter et de
passer une belle leçon non petit garçon
sans lui c'est certain je ne passais pas
la ligne après 42 jours de lutte
quotidienne et incessantes
merci fiston voilà vous savez un peu
mieux pourquoi et comment je suis un
héros ordinaire si tant est que le mot
héros soit le bon ma plus grande force a
été dosé de m'autoriser à vivre l'inédit
qui laisse un avant et un après dans
votre vie et que les choses soient
claires je ne suis pas plus riches
financièrement je ne suis pas plus
connus je me prend pas plus de sérieux
qu'avant
et comme vous pouvez le constater j'ai
pas pris 20 cm dans l'opération et
pourtant qu'est ce que j'ai grandi
qu'est-ce que j'ai grandi alors je veux
vous encourager
ne fuyez pas vos peurs traverser les
appuyer sur le bouton de vos rêves et
transformer en actes concrets fait c'est
si important d'avoir des rêves mais à
quoi ça sert de les avoir si on sait de
votre vie vous tirer votre révérence
sans les avoir réalisées sans même y
avoir goûté et loin de moi l'idée que
tout le monde doit traverser l'océan
atlantique
à chacun ses rêves et possiblement ses
regrets et je dois quand même voulu dire
maintenant qu'on se connaît un peu mieux
quand on ose ses rêves
il ya quand même deux énormes risques le
premier c'est de réussir
vous n'imaginez même pas tout ce que
vous êtes capable de faire aucun rêve
n'est impossible
aucun et le deuxième il est inéluctable
c'est de grandir quelle bonne nouvelle
la décision vous appartient vous pouvez
vous autorisez vous avez le pouvoir
doser
alors qu'est ce que vous faites qu'est
ce que vous faites
quel plaisir
je veux avoir à tous voir grandir à
votre tour
ici commence l'aventuré merci
[Applaudissements]